John Dickerson covered McCain's
political career for more than 20 years
including his presidential campaigns in
2000 and 2008 John is in Mishawaka
Indiana with a look back at McCain's
life and legacy John I have to say you
were the first people I thought about
you and Megan McCain when I heard the
news of his passing late Saturday
because I know how close you were to the
McCain family good to see you this
morning
yeah thanks Gail and when you hear about
John McCain passing with his friends and
family it really was the way he would
have wanted to go and though it's
terribly sad news for the family I think
they feel really strengthened by the way
that that John McCain was able to go out
on his own terms as a Senator John
McCain forged reputation as a champion
of bipartisanship during his more than
three decades in the Senate some of the
conservative Republicans closest friends
and collaborators were Democrats Ted
Kennedy of Massachusetts Joe Lieberman
of Connecticut and Russ Feingold of
Wisconsin McCain challenged lawmakers to
set aside party loyalty and work
together a standard he tried not always
successfully to live by mr. McCain six
days after learning he had brain cancer
last year Senator John McCain bucked his
party and cast the deciding vote to save
Obamacare stop listening to the
bombastic loudmouths on the radio and
television and the Internet to hell with
them he often urged his colleagues to
ignore extreme voices even in the White
House some half-baked spurious
nationalism cooked up by people who
would rather find scapegoats than solve
problems the son and grandson of
admirals John Sidney McCain graduated
near the bottom of his class at the
Naval Academy
in 1967 he was shot down over Vietnam
imprisoned and tortured at the notorious
Hanoi Hilton refusing early release and
staying for nearly six years he later
worked to normalize relations with
Vietnam the war hero left the Navy in
1980 the day his father was buried and
found a new way to serve as an elected
official and no improper behavior
involved in this
after being singed for his role in the
Keating five corruption scandal in the
late 1980s McCain pushed for reform of
campaign finance laws and we came to
power to change Washington and
Washington changed us he built his 2000
presidential campaign around that issue
and nearly knocked off the party
establishment favorite george w bush in
the 2008 campaign McCain wanted to pick
Democratic Senator Joe Lieberman as his
running mate but instead picked Alaska
governor Sarah Palin that decision to
woo the party's diehards foreshadowed
the ascendancy of president Donald Trump
and the seemingly irresistible pole of
the Republican Party fringe which he
memorably resisted in the final days of
his 2008 campaign I can't trust Obama I
have read about him and he's not he's
not he's a he's an Arab he is not no no
man no ma'am he's a he's a he's a decent
family man citizen that I just happened
to have disagreements with Senator
McCain was married twice and had seven
children during his final months a
steady stream of friends visited him at
his favorite spot on his deck in Sedona
Arizona where he loved to grill Norah
it's nice to see him there in his
favorite spot and one of his other
favorite spots was on the campaign trail
John where you and I spent many a miles
out there with him not only in the
Senate campaigns but in the 2000 2008
riding the straight-talking Express he
was sarcastic he was funny but he also
gave it back a lot to reporters and even
people that were there in the audience
sometimes
remember for us to what you found some
of the two highlights of their time with
him well you've characterized it exactly
perfectly Nora and and it was that this
word is so overused in politics but the
authenticity it's one thing to talk
about being open to other ideas but it's
quite another thing for voters to see
you in a town hall engaging with
somebody who is criticizing you who's
really giving it to you and and giving
it right back to them it's one thing to
talk about bipartisanship but to show it
like that is what voters found so
attractive about John McCain I know you
let you love the story of Mike Christian
when when politicians talk about
patriotism that's one thing when John
McCain tells the story of Mike Christian
who sewed the American flag inside his
prison uniform in the Hanoi Hilton and
people openly weep that is connecting
with voters in a way that is so much
more powerful than lots of the precooked
lines that politicians just sort of
shoot over their heads at rallies in
many of the politics we see today when
he served this country so dutifully not
only in the military but in public
service John thank you so much